i love a good rainfall
the sound the smell and the mist on my
skin
it's all very relaxing
but i don't think i'd be able to enjoy
it like this if i didn't have a safe dry
place to enjoy it from
i love the feeling of coldness and the
wind on my skin because i know there's
warmth and a shelter place in just a
couple footsteps a really great home a
house that doesn't just provide shelter
but a house that inspires you and
invigorates your senses
a house like that it lets us experience
both protection and exposure
by carefully mediating between the
outside and the inside world
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dammy and i
am a licensed architect in a very
wet rainy vancouver vc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design and today we'll
be talking about design strategies that
take advantage of the condition
environments
and also the exposed unconditioned
environments this is a part of a design
series where i try to break down some of
the lessons that i learned on my road
trip where i visited 111 frank lloyd
wright buildings scattered across north
america as well as some proven
strategies from books like the good
house and the good old ching book
i'll leave the links to these books
below
so apparently frank lloyd wright
jokingly said a good building should let
the rain lincoln a little because he
understood what a wonderful experience
it is to experience the weather from a
dry safe comforts of your home i'm sure
there's architects who introduce water
in accidentally
but once your building is watertight
introducing water as a experiential
element
it can really elevate your designs
there's a couple ways you can do this
you can introduce a roof with deep eaves
where people can sit inside near an open
window
and
watch the landscape and listen to the
rain and smell the rain in this case the
overhang forms a boundary between the
wet and the dry areas
a porch is also a wonderful thing
it can serve as an extension of the
living room it animates the building
it animates the streetscape and it's a
place where your family can get together
to experience a summer storm you can
also use little details to introduce
water
japanese homes typically have a deep
overhang and the water from the roof
drains down an exposed drain rather than
through a downspout and it creates this
really delicate pattern of light when
the water trickles down the chain
frank lloyd wright was heavily inspired
by japanese architecture and he
incorporated chains into a lot of his
designs one of his homeowners said that
when the rain falls it sounds like a
waterfall in the summer the chain
becomes a memory of the rainfall
i think one of the best things in life
is sitting by a campfire on a chilly
evening you could incorporate this into
your house by introducing an outdoor
fireplace or a fire circle in the
backyard or an outdoor barbecue pit if
you want to incorporate an element you
can touch
materials with thermal mass and a south
facing wall is also an elegant solution
thermal mass of course is the ability
for the material to absorb and hold heat
for a long period of time which is why
when you sit on a stone bench on a sunny
day you can feel the heat on your skin
frank lloyd wright used not just
thermally massive materials but radiant
floor heating in all of his homes in his
signature cherokee red floor tiles he
was the first architect in north america
to popularize the system and fun fact
a lot of people think he took this when
he was on his trip to japan which is
true
but
radiant floors were never a part of
traditional japanese architecture
when he was in japan he was invited to a
japanese home
and the homeowners had visited korea
which actually does have a very long
history of using heated stones to warm
the floors and it's called under and i
actually have very distinct memories of
sitting and playing and sleeping on
the warm floors of my grandma's house
when i was a kid and this is definitely
something i want to incorporate into my
own home someday
you could also include a south-facing
reading nook where you can sit and take
in the warmth of the sun even when the
room itself is cool
another way of linking hot and cold is
to create an outdoor room that's open to
the garden or the yard and it's
partially roofed and it's surrounded by
at least two to three walls of the house
to create a sense of enclosure the room
is typically large enough to have a
dining table and chairs
and
it has a fireplace to warm you in the
evenings during the hot summers it
creates a border between the cool
interior and the hot exterior an nook is
a very nice way to connect the fire and
the rest of the room typically it has a
lower ceiling than the rest of the room
and benches at right angles on either
sides and because it's an enclosed
environment that's still a part of the
rest of the room you can experience both
the controlled warmth of the fireplace
and the coolness of the rest of the room
so my friends and i go camping in bc
once a year and we've been doing this
for about 10 years now and one of the
years we decided
okay let's just invest in a good tent
because there's five of us and we always
bring our own separate tents and we
usually don't have space for it in the
car
and it's just a huge hassle and so we
were just like okay let's go to costco
let's invest in a good tent and so this
tent is amazing
it fits all five of us and there's a top
layer that can be opened up and
it just leaves this
mesh and sometimes we
just open it up when it's warm so that
we can look at the stars
and it just brings in this
wonderful
refreshing
warm summer breeze that is just so
delightful and
although you're sleeping
on the ground
on an air mattress
i
get the most amazing night sleep
i think the feeling of wind on your skin
is a tactile and it's a very pleasant
experience
but if you don't properly protect the
space by contrasting it with still air
it can get pretty
unpleasant
a partly enclosed courtyard is a good
way to control the wind so that you can
experience a little bit of both when we
went to visit the alhambra in granada we
had to walk up this hill and our whole
walk up there was very very windy
and as soon as we walked into the
courtyard i was amazed by
the stillness
and quiet and you know i couldn't hear
the wind and i think more than the
visual
separation the acoustic and tactile
separation made the space feel much more
unique there are some ways to replicate
this condition when you're designing a
house in the 1920s sleeping porches were
very popular
where you had a bed in a cover porch or
an outdoor living room and that just
sounds so wonderful
it kind of reminds me of being a kid
again and finally i'd like to share a
quick message from our sponsor pacific
arc who have kindly provided me with all
the tools that i'm using in this video
so when i was in architecture school i
couldn't afford to buy nice pens or
pencils because they're all quite
expensive pacific art is great because
they carry high quality architecture
supplies at a very affordable price i
think good quality tools should be
available to everyone no matter where
you are in your architectural journey
because
it's a very long journey
and the tools that you draw with it
makes a really big difference
if you enjoy sketching with something
the chances are you are going to sketch
more which is how you get better i've
been working with pacific arc to curate
a kit of products on their website which
you can find in the description
and if you use my promo code you can get
an additional 20 off all of their
products if you're interested in more
design strategies check out my other
video where i show you how you can
control the inside and outside
conditions to create contrast when
you're designing a house i'll leave it
right here
you might also be interested in
strategies that you can use to present
your design i have a video on four
presentation tips i'll leave it right
here if you enjoyed this video please
give me a thumbs up if you're not
subscribed and want to see more design
strategies please subscribe
and if you have any other design
strategies that you want to learn about
leave it in the comments and i will try
to get to them as fast as possible
and with that i'll see you in the next
video
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you